[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Josh Radner AKA
Lonnie flash AKA The Master of Disguise
and Hunter season two which is out
Friday on Prime video how you doing
today Josh yeah I'm good how are you I'm
doing great man uh so I'm really excited
for people to see the season it is
totally awesome so there was this big
break between the two seasons what's
that one thing as an actor you have to
do to like tap into Lonnie flash like
what brings you back there I just got to
get the facial hair on and I gotta get
in the costume and then I'm back like no
no nothing else needed I love it perfect
simple I love it was there anything also
about this season two script that when
you first read it that made you extra
excited about this season
I mean
like for my character like the first
time you see him he's he's at a press
junket not not unlike the one we're
doing right now but in person
uh he's I think in Spain and Barcelona
and he's being ridiculous and then you
realize like oh he's he's using drugs
again you know so
you know you you there's sir there's
things that you want to play as an actor
that you would be you would never want
to happen in your real life right like
so I I'm just thrilled to be able to
play a character that's this
it complicated he's he's a narcissist
he's incredibly insecure he's grandiose
he's filled with shame he's a drug
addict he's trying to be sober he wants
to be a good person but he's an idiot a
lot you know there's so many uh points
of tension internally with him that he's
just he's just the best he's so fun to
play yeah that's a great answer that's
what I love about the character too is
how many layers are to this character
and yeah a lot of interesting things
happen this season with Lonnie which is
great now with this being the final
season is it extra emotional for you
saying goodbye to Lonnie and is there
anything like you'll always keep with
you forever from this show
well when we were filming it it was kind
of I mean I had the sense maybe that
would be the end but we didn't we didn't
know it was definite you know so it
wasn't like the whole last season was
this big farewell tour we were just
shooting it and had a great time and
wrapped up in Prague which was
incredible
um what was the other part of your
question forgive me no I was just saying
what will you keep with you from this
experience oh yeah
uh well I didn't keep any of those
shirts maybe I should have but
you know I think that he he he allowed
me to be
um you know I'm from Ohio and we're a
modest people and uh he just allowed me
to be to give voice to to it to a
different aspect of myself that I don't
let run wild you know the kind of
peacocking look at me aren't I the best
um you know he's an he's a he he likes
attention in a way that I don't
particularly but he helped me uh get a
little more comfortable with that I love
that and the last question I have to ask
you before I let you go it's on
everyone's mind with the way the
industry's been going do you safely have
all of the How I Met Your Mother DVD box
set somewhere do you have them protected
I think my parents do okay yeah I don't
I don't have them but I think they're I
think they're safe in Ohio somewhere I
love it that's good to hear so everyone
can relax good everybody watch Josh kill
it in Hunter's season two on Prime video
Friday thank you so much Josh for
joining me we'll talk to you in the
future one day oh yeah good to talk to
you